parfois très agitée il vous fera
toujours
vous l'avez deviné il s'agit du sommeil
et si dans sa vie un homme dort en
moyenne 25 ans n'est pas le cas de tout
le monde car entre le stress la chaleur
ou le voisin qui fait du bruit en pleine
nuit pas toujours facile de ne pas être
réveillé fermer sa gueule selon un
sondage ifop un tiers des français
souffriraient d'insomnie régulière mais
à qui la faute des écrans serait la
principale cause d altération de la
qualité de notre sommeil avec 6 heures
30 de sommeil par nuit les français
dorment en moyenne une heure trente de
moins qu'il ya 50 ans heureusement qu'il
ya l'été pour attraper des heures
perdues ou pas ce soir le spécialiste
benjamin luc hinse qui étaient avec nous
il va vous donner tous les meilleurs
conseils pour dormir sur ses deux
oreilles
[Musique]
bonjour benjamin si vous avez je vais
bien dormir ça s'apprend c'est vrai
qu'on a tous des mauvaises habitudes
c'est vous c'est vous absolument pas au
niveau qui
globalement petit constat sur le sommet
des français est ce que les français
majoritairement dans bien un français
sur deux se plaint de son sommeil on
sait que deux tiers des français ne
dorment pas huit heures par nuit et on
sait qu'en 50 ans on a perdu une heure
trente de sommeil donc non les français
dorment mal ils ne s'en rendent pas
forcément compte et pour rebondir un peu
tout à l'heure sur le débat 16% des
français dorment avec leur animal de
compagnie je sais pas si vous êtes pour
ou contre dormir avec son animal j'ai
dormi avec jean-michel
oui il est bien domestiques il est très
doux rachat de pa il a le poil doux
[Rires]
ou sacha tout son charme ben le problème
c'est que ça crée des raies certaines
personnes
c'est le temps qui arrive au cerveau
j'allais répondre à la question sérieuse
gauche est désolé
avec mon chien par exemple
une personne c'est
ma famille mon chien oui j'adore j'ai
des pyrénées j'ai un jak 2 ans le petit
jack russell il adore rentrée sous le
drap et ils sont sept
[Rires]
le moral au travail et là c'est l'été
nous dénigrer
dak lak
si j'aurais cru chienne ouais ça vous
aide à dormir
mais
quand on sent quelque chose qu'on sait
pas si elle va chez eux est là mais elle
m'apaise moi babbino
dormir avec ces élections sont son chien
son chat ça dépend si on dort bien il
n'ya pas il n'y a pas de règle en
revanche on sait que par exemple 50% des
réveils sont liées aux partenaires de
lit donc dans un monde très triste on
devrait dormir seul dans sa chambre et
mais bon ensuite retrouvé cul pour
copuler à dans un monde dans un monde
idéal pour le sommeil mais déprimant
pour tout le reste on est d'accord
une question est ce que en fait de leur
mire trop proche de son partenaire c'est
pas bon non plus pour le sommeil le
partenaire bausch il ya les ronflements
pas réveillé
donc c'est vraiment très courant et ça
vraiment ça abîme le sommeil alors
question qui peut paraître idiot mais
pourquoi est ce important de bien dormir
c'est important de bien dormir parce que
c'est bon pour les défenses immunitaires
parce que ça permet d'avoir de l'énergie
se sentir de se sentir bien pas fatigué
j'aurais agi sur sa baisse le stress
s'abaisse la déprime ça augmente votre
espérance de vie s'est vite le diabète
l'obésité enfin le sommeil sert à tout
réparer c'est aussi simple que l'on y en
a qui ont l'impression que l'on pourrait
un peu négocié avec le sommeil alors je
vais prendre un petit peu de temps sur
mon sauveur je suis gardien arrivé je
suis comme ça je vais récupérer une
heure mais non ça marche pas alors
est-ce qu'on est tous égaux en nombre
d'heures de sommeil parce que moi et je
connais des gens qui veulent du mal moi
je dors quatre heures sur belle forme
affichée par quatre heures c'était donc
une journée
mais regarde
y'a pas de règle majorité a quand même
besoin de dormir entre 7 et 9 heures la
moyenne est vraiment vu qu'il faut 9
heures
mais disons que la moyenne ce qu'on doit
essayer de viser ses huit heures et mais
il ya des exceptions et des gens qui
sont les gros dormeurs qui peuvent aller
jusqu'à 12 heures des petits dormeurs le
meilleur indicateur c'est l'état dans
lequel on est le réveil si vous
ressentez travail est ce que pour 12
heures de sommeil à part la poste
n'ont pas vraiment fait ça pour le coup
il a donc fait alors on va dire entre 7
et 9 heures le ballon rond est-ce que
trop dormir c'est pas bon trop dormir
c'est ça peut être mauvais pour la santé
mais le risque principal c'est de ne pas
assez dormir 6 alors ça conserve quand
même deux tiers des français donc on est
sur un phénomène majeur alors qu'est ce
que ce qu'elles sont et listes de
comptes on dort pas assez les risques
pour la santé ils s'opposent bas diabète
à la corde des rues m'enfin c'est celle
joue surtout sur le stress le sommeil la
dépression s'agit vraiment surtout il ya
des gens qui nous regardent qui ont d un
sommet ce qu'on appelle un sommeil h et
ça ça
travaille à moi je m'en allais 00h02 1,6
alors j'ai le sommeil h est facile plein
de raisons mais ça peut être par exemple
des décalages de rythme si vous coucher
une fois une heure du matin et ensuite
10 heures non en se couchant à la même
heure on se réveille tôt mérite d'être
fait peur on t'aura du réveil nom n'a
pas encore un souci du sommeil assez
grand et quand on va voir un généraliste
est pas une question habituelle comment
dormez vous or maintenant il ya des
polices autographes on peut analyser
tout ça dans le détail et puis si le
matin vous réveillez vous êtes crever
bah ouais faut en parler à son médecin
c'est clairement est ce qu il est vrai
que si on se couche avant minuit on a un
meilleur sommeil beaucoup plus rêveurs
récupérateur alors c'est pas minuit qui
compte fausse couche et au moment où on
est fatigué si vous cochez au moment où
vous êtes fatigués les premières heures
voire du sommeil lent et profondeur si
vous voulez améliorer votre sommeil vous
avez du cnoss je fais des séances
d'hypnose par exemple soit dans mon
livre soit sur ma chaîne et l'hypnose ça
a été testée cliniquement ça permette
d'approfondir le sommeil c'est assez
marrant on a testé ça sur des champs
alors à fait imaginer qu'ils étaient des
poissons qu'ils allaient de plus en plus
profondément dans l'océan et on a
dix-sept plus vous allez profondément et
plus vous dormirez profondément il faut
remonter et
profond est excellent et on a vu qu'on
pouvait faire même le contraire c'est un
peu sadique mais si on leur dit d'aller
vers la surface le sommeil devient plus
léché donc il ya des manières
d'améliorer le sommeil l'hypnose la
relaxation font partie comment faire un
pari c'est l'art dé laisser endormir ils
dormaient m'a fait mal alors c'est vrai
que les écrans et la télé va champs sont
néfastes pour le sommeil très ça retarde
la possibilité dans l'arrondissement il
ya un chômage il ya 20 à 25 % des
français qui gardent leur téléphone sur
leur table de chevet est allumée et 50 %
d'entre eux sont prêts à répondre
pendant la nuit ou se font par dont 50%
se sont réveillés par le téléphone et 30
pour cent des gens interrogés sont prêts
à répondre au milieu de la nuit donc
évidemment c'est une tuerie pour pour le
sommeil ce qui est des jambes et ans et
que quand on est exposé à la lumière
bleue ça retarde le moment on va
s'endormir sa inévitablement ça permet
d'avoir un sommet on a un sommeil de
moins grande qualité plus léger et puis
il ya ces problèmes de rêver quoi se
réveillant camus et de la nuit
simplement parce que en docteur quand on
vous appelle en plein milieu de la nuit
c'est son nom une urgence après bien de
répondre aussi une page ou si ma fille
m'appelle en pleine nuit je vais
décrocher j'ai pas de nuire je casse
calme en mer je bien dormir oui mais
vous pouvez sélectionner ces gens qui
peuvent vous appeler
mais le champion d'europe en titre doit
dormir avec des écouteurs ces thèmes
avaient fait ça
j'ai rêvé dans la nuit j'ai branché en
somme aidera et après je me mets en
cuisine elle ou crime avec megafon
minnesota ainsi qu'aux patrons et jeux
avec des histoires ou moins qu'on en
fait c'est des histoires douces en plus
alors qu'elles n'y a pas de problème ce
qu'il faut c'est que ce soit un son qui
soit plus tôt toujours au même niveau
sur si vous endormez par exemple avec
des bruits blanc ce sont des bruits qui
se déroule en débridant bébé chan
exemple des vagues ou le bruit de la
pluie c'est d'aider ceux qui ont une
longueur d'onde qui couvre tous les
autres sont à la ville de trets révélé
donc 6 à annuler le bruit d'une mère
active ou passive et qu'en plus on a le
bruit blanc ça peut améliorer le sommeil
et ma foi sans dormir avec un son ce
n'est pas ce n'est pas dérangeant ce
n'est pas dérangeant alors on parle
souvent des ddd face dans le sommeil on
y aille à la première phase deuxième
phase on fasse profonde
c'est vrai ça
oui d'après la science oui
bien sûr ça se décompose comment le
sommet qui nous intéresse le plus c'est
le sommeil lent et profond danse mais
paradoxal c'est plutôt de ce mail et
chez c'est le moment où on va rêver le
sommeil lent et profond on rêve - mais
c'est le moment où on va on va récupérer
on va aussi mémorisé par exemple si on
est étudiant ou si on doit retenir des
choses il faut dormir bien toutes les
nuits parce que en fait la mémoire court
terme va se verser dans la mare long
terme et il faut dormir bien avant
d'apprendre et après et grâce à sabha
vous augmentez la mémorisation sans rien
faire doit tant qu à bachoter autant
d'acheter est énorme et nous pardonner
toujours d'or son talent sowie donc en
gros aventure mais mon bon monsieur les
avez raison
avant de t'endormir tube à bulles à
mémoriser c'est vrai c'est un truc de
grand mère où c'est vrai faire ça c'est
plutôt de l'ordre de la légende mais en
revanche ce qui est sûr c'est que si
vous dormez bien vous 8h en vous
couchant à l'heure habituelle vous
memory serez mieux et au lieu de le
retenir pendant un ou deux choses vous
allez le retenir définitivement cas
sinon alors qu'est ce qu'on peut dire
aux gens qui nous regardent pour
améliorer leur sommeil et des risques
d'alimentation a des conséquences sur un
lit alors on dit qu'il faut plutôt
manger d'une manière légère le soir
avant de se coucher mais c'est pas le
plus important le plus important mais je
vais me faire détester c'est vrai que je
parle de ces il faut arrêter de regarder
son téléphone une heure avant d'aller se
coucher papa trop de patrons du délai
les excitants évidemment il ça il faut
essayer de les arrêter au moins avant 14
heures sinon ça la demi vie de la
caféine ses 6 à 12 heures donc ça peut
rester quand même longtemps même le dca
est à déconseiller parce que ça contient
encore de la caféine le laisser le lay à
paris l'euro sont chaudes
sont pleins il ya des techniques qui
sont tellement mieux que ça et faire
l'amour vous êtes très bon pour le moral
et pour le sommeil bien sûr comme
dessinateur a dit merde y'a tout changé
d'émerger une question est ce que c'est
normal parce que en vrai vous dit de pas
regarder son téléphone et ses mémoires
en fait j'ai besoin de me fatiguer les
yeux pour m'endormir je voudrais parler
des gens c'est pas qu'à moi et en fait
il faut que je sois joly soit je regarde
les téléphones
soit je regarde mon téléphone je fais
des trucs tueur et c'est ça qui me
fatigue les yeux qui a le vent dans mes
retours je fais pas ça je dors pas
demandez vous occuper l'esprit mais
c'est vrai que tant qu'à ça il vaut
mieux lire parce que vous n'aurez pas et
comme ça de la lumière bleue en direct
dans la réforme rendra mire des chars
préparés vendus sur l'alimentation sur
l'alimentation saine chaban dormir
on peut s'endormir pendant
de l'autre c'est pas c'est pas le plus
important aller mieux avoir mangé de mer
légère le soir mais ce qui va empêcher
de s'endormir c'est la lumière c'est
s'il ya trop de chaleur si la literie
est mauvaise surtout si on est stressé
en fait ya trois grandes raisons qui
expliquent les insomnies c'est se sentir
mal dans le corps pour une raison ou une
autre la douleur par exemple 1 un tiers
des français souffrent de douleur
chronique pour eux c'est red lion d'or
merlot ah bah oui oui oui bah c'est le
mal du siècle un cellier à la
sédentarité c'est lié au niveau de
stress et le problème c'est que s'ils ne
dorment pas bien et ils ont du mal à
récupérer avec ça joue aussi sur leur
état de santé ensuite il faut être le
plus calme possible stress est vraiment
l'ennemi du sommeil est la dernière
chose et qui est difficile c'est de ne
pas se forcer à dormir plus on essaie de
dormir moi on y arrive et c'est pour ça
que la plupart des gens utilisent des
dérives anniv
alors on parle souvent de malades et
tout ce qui est petit côté rock
somnifères et autres donc mélatonine
siro ça m'a jamais fait dormir ça mais
bon est-ce que vous vous dormez bien
rejoindre la violentant vous dormez bien
oui j'ai une obligation professionnelle
où il y avait des faits des français
consomment énormément de somnifères
c'est bon parce qu'on dit que chagrin
son amant avec d'autres compacts
d'endormis soeurs qui sont moins forts
que ceux qui vont vous mettre un coup
sur la carafe ça limite la qualité du
sommeil on peut faire bien mieux c'est à
dire qu'on peut par exemple est une
méthode que j'adore qui s'appelle la
méthode jacobson on contracte les
muscles on les fatigue et après on se
détend donc vous fait sa partie du corps
après parties du corps ont directement
tout le corps comme ça on fait ça 4,5
fois on se détend et après c'est
beaucoup plus facile de s'endormir et
puis si on a du mal autant écouter des
choses comme de l'hypnose la méditation
de la smr tout ce qui va vous apprendre
à détendu et à ne pas mettre d'enjeu
pour l'endormissement tisane sommeil
alors c'est quoi la méthode la méthode
du quai de 7,8
c'est une méthode qui est vendue comme
étant miraculeuse c'est censé vous
endormir en moins de trois minutes je
pense que c'était un peu survendu on met
la langue en hauteur dans la bouche on
inspire sur quatre secondes on retient
ensuite sa respiration sur sept et en
heure on est
parce qu en fait toutes les techniques
de respiration vise à - reste un regret
quand on est stressé on a trop d'oxygène
dans le sang donc le but de toutes les
techniques de respiration c'est ralentir
la respiration diminué l'oxygène
augmenter le co2 donc non heureusement
y'a pas il ya pas de risque et ça marche
si on en a une pratique extrêmement
régulière en fait il ya plein de méthode
qui marche simplement elles sont peu
connus et comme c'est plus facile de
croquer un anxiolytique un somnifère
écouter son corps bien sur wii et
surtout ça abîme la qualité du sommeil
question comment on fait pour éviter les
cauchemars
je regarde sa médecine doha mais des
fois je rêve que je montre à des classes
déjà chez toi
c'est pas gentil
des rêves le harcèlement au travail peut
créer
d'accord faut le dire
sur wii c'est possible il ya une
technique en tcc qui est assez simple en
fait c'est un entraînement mental on
s'imagine vivant le cauchemar nan nan
change la fin on reprend le contrôle et
le fait de le faire comme ça très
régulièrement permet d'éviter les
cauchemars d'en diminuer la quantité est
d'éviter surtout les cauchemars
répétitif et puis faisait aussi une
chose c'est que en général plus on est
stressé avant d'aller se coucher plus on
a des cauchemars donc si vous relaxer
vraiment hyper bien être fortes chances
qu'ils disparaissent dernière chose
augmenter le temps de sommeil lent et
profond c'est un moment il ya très peu
de rêve très peu de cauchemar et donc ça
permet comme ça d' éviter aussi une
bonne quantité de mauvais rêves est
question est ce que c'est important de
faire une sieste pour ceux qui peuvent
la faire évidemment à la sieste
c'est un micro sur 5 5 à 10 minutes il
faut pas dépasser une demi-heure
d'accord 15 minutes 25 minutes c'est
très bien ça et non pas des siestes
royal c'est assez lisse yes on soumet
comme ça qui ont fait 2 heures 10 bah
oui parce qu'on vende d un sommeil
profond donc on sait le seul que je ne
vais pas la nuit
c'est ça le problème sexy si vous dormez
pendant deux heures l'après midi vous
aurez du mal à vous endormir le soir et
votre sommeil sera de mauvaise qualité
donc les gens qui font des 16 3 et rial
il faut éviter vaut mieux faire quinze
minutes 20 minutes deux siestes là ça
permet d'avoir un bon saut mais ensuite
et de récupérer et aussi à demi nu
toutes les trois minutes gégé national
j'ai une astuce génial c'est jennifer
donc de l'attak m'avait donné en fait
pour tenir une cuillère commençait à
s'endormir et une fois que vous lâchez
la cuillère pas il faut se réveiller et
vous avez dormi à peu près et ça marche
comme ça marche on peut prendre un
bouquin aussi mais
ce sera le mot de la fin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]